et pour parler de ce rapport de la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme
nous sommes en direct avec jean marie
burguburu président de la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme bonjour jean marie burguburu
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france alors le nombre de crimes
racistes et délits un repart à la hausse
en 2010 9 après trois années
consécutives de baisse 1 justement
comment on peut l'expliquer aujourd'hui
il ya deux aspects d'une part
effectivement une augmentation des
crimes racistes des délits racistes mais
également sur doute et il faut s'en
réjouir si j'ose dire une augmentation
des déclarations car il a toujours une
sous-déclaration des injures des délits
des crimes racistes
je ne parle pas des crimes violence bien
sûr mais des délits racistes qui sont
les injures raciales
les comportements racistes que les
victimes hésitent à déclarer ou même
quand ils les déclare que les autorités
policières sont un peu réticente a
enregistré autrement dit il n'y a pas
assez de plainte les plaintes augmentent
ça veut dire la foi qui est un cercle
une augmentation des délits racistes
mais ça veut dire aussi une augmentation
des déclarations donc une meilleure
prise en compte par les autorités de ces
délits racistes
vous avez dit à nos confrères de france
info que le racisme était sous-évalué en
france qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
par là oui il reste sous-évalué
justement à cause de ses soutes des
éclairs un ti cul donc au jeu des
absences de déclaration
il ya ce qu'on appelle un chiffre noir
de la criminalité c'est raciste et dans
d'autres domaines aussi et également
parce que lorsque ces affaires arrivent
devant le tribunal souvent cela donne
lieu à des relaxes faute de preuves il y
avait une question de preuves aussi des
délits racistes l'injure raciste contre
une personne ou un groupe de personne si
elle est verbale la preuve est parfois
difficile en apporter s'il n'y a pas de
témoin et ici elle est écrite alors là
il faut rapporter la preuve écrite bien
sûr c'est le cas notamment pour les
fameux problèmes de
n en ligne de racisme en ligne mais il
ya une chose évaluation par ce que les
victimes ne sont pas toujours assez
active pour dénoncer les attaques qui
sont portées à leur encontre
donc nous encourageons les victimes à
dénoncer plus facilement les auteurs que
couramment les auteurs des injures et
des actes racistes à leur encontre
alors vous avez rendu à votre rapport au
cabinet du premier ministre récemment
aujourd'hui que qu'attendez-vous de
l'exécutif je vais vous dire ce n'est
pas au cabinet du premier ministre au
premier ministre lui même que j'ai remis
le rapport hier et le ministre était
entouré de la garde des sceaux de la
sécurité à deraa marlène schiappa et de
même si bête n'diaye porte parole du
gouvernement
donc si tu volontairement une certaine
solennité qui a présidé la remise de ce
rapport
ce rapport contient un certain nombre de
recommandations c'est un rapport au
rapport de 365 pages
il contient 59 récommandations à son
issue et c'est targon dation sont bien
sûr destinée à être mise en oeuvre
mais notre commission n'a pas de pouvoir
d'injonction envers le gouvernement
elle a un pouvoir consultatif et à
pouvoir de recommandation
parmi ces recommandations si vous ne me
laissez le temps de le faire j'aimerais
en citer quelques-unes
par exemple les vingt ans très bien le
sujet est à l'ordre du jour et bien
demandé aux forces de l'ordre d'une part
de sensibiliser les fonctionnaires à
l'accueil des victimes c'est la suite de
ce que je vous disais il ya un instant
que les commissariats de police
contiennent des hommes et des femmes qui
soit vigilante pour accueillir
favorablement lorsqu'elles sont fondées
elles le sont la plupart du temps les za
atteinte raciale raciste de nature
raciste et que dont les victimes se font
l'écho
c'est là un premier point c'est
important car c'est le début d'un
processus judiciaire qui va aller
jusqu'au tribunal
lorsque la fer se poursuit également
l'égard des forces de l'ordre un
meilleur contre
du reste ce pet des obligations
déontologiques des policiers pour faire
en sorte qu'il n'y ait plus de contrôles
au faciès
les contrôles publicités sont soit
spontanément par les policiers soient
sur réquisition du procureur les casses
à répétition respecter et en aucun cas
ce doit être un contrôle au faciès
il y à d'autres recommandations comme
par exemple demandé au csa conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel d'encourager
une meilleure représentation des
personnes noires hommes et femmes à la
télévision dans les médias au visuel et
pas seulement pour des rôles subalternes
mais pour des rôles d' expertise pour
des rôles de premier plan nous pourrons
pas que le noir soit un faire valoir
d'une personne blanche
suivant les scénarios qui sont adoptés
vous voyez-vous toutes ces
recommandations il y en a d'autres bien
sûr très nombreux 59 vous ai-je dit et
sont de nature à peu à peu agir sur la
vie quotidienne car le racisme est une
vigilance de tous les instants
il ya même entend nombre dont nous dire
une sorte de racisme impensé il y à des
personnes qui estiment qu'elles ne sont
pas racistes et dont pourtant le
comportement est raciste parce qu'elle
déprécie les personnes de race noire et
chose curieuse et notre rapport le
relève les personnes de couleur noire on
ne parle plus de race dans la vie
publique française
le mot race a disparu de la constitution
il ya une race humaine points quelle que
soit la couleur des hommes et des femmes
merci merci beaucoup jean marie
burguburu d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france rappelle que vous êtes
président de la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme merci
beaucoup